this is the story of one big family I'm
Xin Engvall and this handsome daddy is
my husband bill these are our kids
PJ Bryn Barney Bancroft Becky built slow
down please and Beit Ron that's 17 kids
and all give or take but I could fit
much more in my family so I'm pregnant
again we always do we didn't want a
typical family we wanted a farm of kids
today is charity day so we're raising
money to help a family in need ours
that's right
to raise the money the boys and girls
will be engaging in a friendly
competition we wash the cars which is a
boy job and we did a girl job stirring
powder into water to make lemonade drink
to make the car washed as cost-effective
as possible we've been collecting our
soapy bath water for weeks
self tastes like ass the boys here team
boys we win charity day every single
year but who knows you know maybe this
year the girl to win that better mix it
up then the girls would be winners and
the boys who have the babies that's good
son that's good the car wash was
supposed to be for boys only but I got
to be part of it because I'm marrying BJ
and so now I'm part of him kind of like
how Eve was part of Adam cuz she was
made from his rib yeah I'm his bone it's
like God gave me a little boner and now
I put a ring on it
lemonade fresh nourishing lemonade it's
nice to know we're selling something to
the community that's actually good for
them hmm oh that's gross that is gross
uh still gross Jamie's lemonade tastes
like fire yeah I was drinking it's like
I'm a free spirit you know I like to get
crazy I like to get nuts um super
entertaining I could almost I could
almost have like my own you know like
spin-off cousin Jamie coming at you
after kid farm Thursdays at 8:00 the
more lemonade cousin Jamie has the more
she spits on me when she talks
oh look boys it's sheepy he wants a car
wash - hey looks like the girls don't
stand a chance
I hate cars cuz I'm not allowed to drive
only one of my eyes work but Daniel my
little sweetie let mommy help you okay
gene evil is so creative she has the
biggest set of brains I just wish I had
her brains in my mouth in my skull just
oh you're so smart
Oh feelings and women average eat no I
want milk later heroin
then nothing thank you dad says we can't
buy cow's milk because it's a waste
moms lactating most of the year thick
mom got into an onion patch we are doing
great we have made 48 dollars a little
weird cuz we're charging $10 a car but I
don't encourage math math leads to grams
and grams are a type of drug hey cousin
Jamie are we going on spell short for
uncle are you okay Jamie I think you've
been outside too long you better have
some more of that lemonade get that in
yeah hydration I just wanted to see how
the girls are doing we've made we've
made 19 $19 okay yeah ninety nine ninety
as in almost 100 as in pretty close to a
hug oh I'm gonna make a phone call in
the house on the landline new year long
forgot
that does nothing the charity day was
great nothing could go wrong wait are
you gonna put that right before
something goes wrong hi sir would you
like some lemonade how old are you
little lady my dad says I'm not allowed
to count until I'm married
will you marry me Oh welcome to our
charity day what's the charity oh it's a
day when the kids work you know we keep
the money but ma'am I'm with Child
Protective Services are you aware of
child labor laws I think I know a thing
or two about children and labor
I have 17 Kids and Counting that's why
we call it a kid farm and so we don't
have to change the name of the show
every season whatever hey hot ass oh
yeah I hit on that CPS officer cuz I'm
crazy I'm always getting into crazy
situations that's why you should check
me out every night after kid farm it's
cousin Jamie Jamie we already said no
come on give me a shot I'm fun this girl
is clearly intoxicated are you sorting
alcohol serving up a piping hot oh
listen no sir please
we don't even clean our rooms with
alcohol in this house pickle juice is
good iodine okay I'm shutting down this
entire operation kids yes back inside
love the sponges drop the squeegee zone
no now we'll never know if the boys are
the girls one but probably
boys let's just shut it down and never
think of it again
we raised a ton of money for charity
today but unfortunately we had to give
all of it over to Child Protective
Services to pay our fine you know looks
like it's lemonade powder for dinner
again hey hey hold on uh who reported
this
it was a Bill Engvall sumer was that guy
not the comedian I I called Child
Protective Services um I couldn't let
the girls win I mean I mean they can win
but if the girls win just the girls win
but if the boys win everybody wins
because the boys win and then the girls
win because they get to feel good for
the boys winning it's a girl thing wait
17 kids but how big is their [ __ ] you
know I know a lot of kids we need a nice
warm home and probably put a bunch of
them in her big ass [ __ ]
Oh